it is the most modern and advanced trade
agreement ever made actually and it
opens up fantastic possibilities for
entrepreneurs and companies and
consumers in Europe but also in Canada
and it strengthened of course the very
tight friendship and Alliance we have
with our Canadian friends Canada is said
of 12 trading partners it's about 60
billion a year of trading goods out with
less than 30 billion trading services
it's a huge investor in Europe there's
more than hundred twenty billion of
Canadian euros of Canadian investment in
Europe some present up in quezon Danny
Oh Canada
no I was on Tony Danza poops on that
machine de faire I become your own icons
me tell ya Elodie Lacoste near
negotiations between European in Canada
panoramic her W win or lose a shoe rack
you can another so sue whoever her to
the competitive et merci beaucoup
presence on Russia Canada knock-on
invisibility freeze importance under the
attractive for lutorius machine improve
the gas and Killian chosen ser una
cadena monkey on Canadian Kiki M Nova
nunca
- sighs - deposit if it wasn't Arizona
damn dishwasher Eagle more emo thank you
looking at up
dredging equipment is excluded from the
coastal trade act by Sita so that will
help us to use our foreign equipment in
Canada it's not our intention to take
over the market of local contractors but
it's our intention to join forces with
them and to work together to bigger
projects which are not feasible before
Canada is a big country quantities to
Canada are more important
Canadians are very fond of Italian PDO
cheese's in general Grana Padano and
parmigiano-reggiano in particular I
expect advantages from SATA agreement we
expect many people to impact positively
antonova new jobs and positive spillover
on the communities where we are
parroting we have around 1200 employees
worldwide
out of them 1,000 are in Europe around
700 are here in Germany in Canada the
electrical approvals are different to
the U this is for us a kind of a
challenge since we have to adapt our
products for the Canadian needs and this
is increasing our prices which makes us
difficult to be competitive compared to
local manufacturers we believe that due
to the city--
agreement we can improve our situation
that means that we can increase our
market share in Canada the Canadians
have very similar view to the ones we
have about not only the value of free
trade and in the free economy but also
how if regulate that economy and how
should make sure that free trade does
not damage public policy interest it
simplifies access to the other Canadian
markets we have access to their public
procurement on all levels and they're
actually planning for a lot of
investment in public procurement where
we could bit and it also makes it easier
for our service companies to have access
to the market and for the staff who work
in the service companies to temporarily
come and
that service and it also includes a very
ambitious chapter on sustainable
development where we commit to together
work on issues such as good environment
labor standards etc